all right let's look at some humorous
and funny moments from CPAC 2023 these
are some of my favorite moments from a
comedic standpoint some of you may
remember that 2024 Republican
presidential candidate Nikki Haley
suggested a competency or cognitive test
for any politician age 75 or older now
she overtly meant this for Joe Biden but
part of her campaign against Trump has
been that she's younger and she's from
the Next Generation and so we know that
when she talks about cognitive tests for
those 75 and over she also means and it
would apply to Donald Trump well the
CPAC crowd is very Mega friendly and
they weren't going for it and when Nikki
Haley suggests the cognitive tests the
mental competency tests the crowd is
silent you could hear a pin drop in
there not a Nikki Nikki Haley friendly
crowd and I absolutely love it look at
this when I launched my campaign I said
every petition
okay mental competency test
have you seen DC lately
dead silent
dead silent we should start with Joe
Biden and we shouldn't stop there
okay one person did clap one person did
clap this and many other Clips we're
going to look at today
for me were reminders that this is
Trump's party this genuinely is Trump's
party now I know Nikki Haley spoke I
know Vivek ramaswamy spoke who's also
running for president against Trump but
this was a trump crowd this was a Maga
crowd they love Steve Bannon they loved
Beau bear and Marjorie Taylor green and
the entire thing Carrie Lake they
cheered for all of the election lies and
the entire thing and this is quite
frankly Trump's nomination to lose this
is a line that's done okay in some of
the early primary States when Nikki goes
by herself and it's a Nikki friendly
crowd but CPAC is trumpy Trump is 76 and
they recognize that to some degree what
Nikki Haley is saying would apply to
Trump and they don't like it so a
hilarious and humiliating moment for
Nikki Haley
imagine for a second that you try
logging into your email account only to
find that your password was changed an
hour ago and then you get notifications
of activity from your bank and then your
credit cards that is what identity theft
is like and it's a horrible feeling and
we dealt with it at the show not that
long ago but now I have an app called
Aura which gives me much more peace of
mind our sponsor Aura is the all-in-one
solution for keeping your online account
safe because Aura will scan the dark web
for your personal info passwords social
security number and you get fast alerts
when they find something you also get
fast alerts about credit inquiries Aura
protects all of your devices from
malware or even requests the removal of
your info from data broker sites and
Aura helps you manage what your kids can
do on their devices you can restrict
certain apps set screen time limits set
Focus times when you need them off of
devices is go to aura.com Pacman to try
it free for seven days your login
credentials might already be floating
around out there and Aura will tell you
instantly for free the link is down
below